[Música]
el poder está cambiando el poder está
cambiando
esta mañana pude levantarme
esta mañana pude ir a llevar al colegio
a mi hijo
esta mañana pude decidir no hacer caso a
temas que tenía pendiente y si nos damos
cuenta todas estas frases tienen una
palabra en común en común el poder
y el poder lo han definido a lo largo de
la historia de muchas formas la forma
cómo la sociedad se organiza para que
garantice la existencia
es la forma como nosotros sabemos poder
hoy por hoy a las instituciones para
nacer un estado de derecho que nos
garantice los derechos mínimos para
vivir
ese poder lo podemos definir como
lo que yo puedo hacer hasta que algo o
alguien me lo impida esa sería como la
definición de poder hacer lo que yo
quiero hasta que algo o alguien me lo
impida
y si eso es así y si ha estado siempre
de la mano de la sociedad es importante
ver cómo ha evolucionado el poder para
entender porque hoy tenemos unas
realidades que nosotros veíamos que era
tremendamente predecible cosas que al
final no pasaron y están sucediendo en
todo el mundo sucedió en inglaterra
sucedió en españa' sucediendo a eeuu
sucedió en colombia está sucediendo en
todo el mundo el poder está cambiando
para entenderlo entonces imaginémonos
que estamos en una obra de teatro y
vamos a imaginarnos el poder
en escenas en diferentes momentos del
tiempo si fuéramos a hacer
una obra de teatro en el siglo 18 y en
el siglo 19 pues esa obra de teatro
tendrá solamente un actor
la monarquía el rey porque porque era el
delegado de dios el elegido de dios para
poner control a la sociedad
el monarca dictaba la ley el monarca
decía que había que hacer
y que no ese actor en esa obra de teatro
que también es nuestra realidad nos dice
que es bueno y qué es malo
y estamos hablando de la ética lo que va
en contra de la ley no es ético y lo que
está con la ley si es ético suena un
poco raro pero en el siglo 19 y 18 esa
era la realidad esa era la realidad y
les voy a compartir
la historia de este señor que ven este
señor se llama francisco jose primero
que fue el último archiduque del imperio
austrohúngaro
a él le correspondió vivir una europa
tremendamente agitada donde las ideas
liberales y las ideas democráticas
estaban empezando a cimentarse y le
correspondió vivir en la obra de teatro
donde estaba empezando a tocar la puerta
un nuevo actor
a este señor se le achaca a un pasaje
divertido en el que se dice que él iba
en su carruaje y pidió que abrieran las
cortinas de su carruaje porque le
pareció un poco llamativo ver un
edificio dijo yeso que es y alguien le
dijo mire eso es una forma de
democratizar la tierra en donde usted
construye en una área específica de ahí
para arriba empieza a vivir más gente yo
no me hagan favor me cierran la cortina
porque aquí en viena
deben haber espalda ceos y me la abren
cuando se haya acabado eso
ese es un ejemplo claro
que cuando el poder está cambiando y uno
no quiere ver la realidad de lo que está
sucediendo pueden traer consecuencias
tremendamente complejas como el hecho de
que fue el último archiduque del imperio
austrohúngaro porque después de eso
nunca volvió a existir como consecuencia
de eso la gente se aprovechó que había
necesidades de un lado y había
necesidades de otro
y se generó tanto la primera como la
segunda guerra mundial ahora bien
estamos sino 19 miremos finales del
siglo 19 el siglo 20 en nuestra obra de
teatro estamos diciendo que hay un nuevo
actor empieza a aparecer en ese
escenario un personaje pues que no es de
la nobleza no es de la monarquía
este personaje empieza a comprar títulos
nobiliarios había un nuevo personaje una
nueva variable en la ecuación de poder
un nuevo actor en el poder
que era el tema de la empresa privada y
el mercado el mercado es el nuevo actor
la industria privada la revolución
industrial trajo como consecuencia ese
resto por tratar de socavar el poder que
estaba en la cabeza de una persona para
que se democratizará y estudiara
la consecuencia en su momento de no
haber entendido que el poder estaba
cambiando desafortunadamente llevaron
primero al nacimiento de alemania y al
nacimiento italiano si ustedes tienen
claro nosotros el año entrante vamos a
celebrar el bicentenario de la
existencia de nuestro país y somos más
viejos que alemania y más viejos que
italia estos países nacieron en el año
de 1860 en 1861
como consecuencia de no haber arreglado
bien este nacimiento de estas naciones y
de no haber entendido que el poder
estaba cambiando se suscitó la primera
guerra mundial como una exaltación del
nacionalismo y una segunda guerra
mundial que quería resarcir lo que pasó
en la primera
porque porque no entendimos que el poder
había cambiado y en la escena teatral
estaban dos actores conviviendo la
institucionalidad
y el mercado esa fue la realidad con la
que yo crecí una realidad en donde la
institucionalidad y el mercado mandaban
la parada ahora bien quiero mostrarles
esta foto
esta foto fue tomada en el vaticano en
una época x
y esta foto también fue tomada en el
vaticano
tal vez en el 2005
en el siglo 21
comparemos las
en el siglo 21 esa diferencia la una era
el momento en donde había un muy blanco
en la elección de benedicto 16
y la otra es cuando estaba saliendo humo
blanco en la elección del papá francisco
en el mismo siglo en menos de 10 años la
diferencia en cómo la gente llega a la
información es tremendamente impactante
miren la cantidad de celulares y la
cantidad de información que se traspasa
en un momento yo recuerdo cuando el papa
benedicto xiv 6 fue elegido
lo vimos por televisión era lo más
rápido y estamos hablando del siglo 21
y cuando eligieron a francisco primero
yo lo vi en un tuit
rapidísimo podríamos haber estado en
cualquier lado de un televisor y estamos
hablando del siglo 21
esa situación trajo como consecuencia
un nuevo actor del que les voy a hablar
porque el poder está cambiando a esa
obra de teatro en el siglo 21 tenemos
que invitar a una nueva persona
miremos los hechos este señor que
ustedes ven ahí es mubarak
presidente o dictador como lo quieran
llamar de egipto durante más de tres
décadas
y ninguna fuerza militar lo pudo
derrocar alguien dijo que no estaba
conforme con el presidente y alguien le
dijo yo tampoco y no se conocían y
seguramente por una actividad de
información empezó a gestarse
un movimiento
en el cairo
de caminar hacia la plaza central
y pudieron tumbar al presidente lo que
antes creemos que no podía pasar en el
siglo 21 está pasando y estoy hablando
del año 2010 siglo 21
el nuevo acta el nuevo actor se llama la
legitimidad el poder que todos tenemos
siendo personas tremendamente diferentes
pero con puntos en común
puede que hacia el lado de allá
que mi realidad es la derecha y ustedes
en la izquierda o hacia la izquierda
para ustedes la derecha podamos decir
cosas
pero lo que sí es cierto es que el poder
de lo común tiene más poder que
cualquier otra cosa que haya existido en
la humanidad
sigamos
ustedes ven aquí una familia
no sé qué tan tradicional
norteamericana esta señora que está aquí
fue la primera mujer de afrodescendiente
que aceptó de los eeuu en los años 70
que era lesbiana
en los eeuu en los años 70
y este señor que aparece allí
es su esposo y estos son sus hijos
y este señor que parece ahí
es ni más ni menos que el actual alcalde
de nueva york
como es posible que una ciudad
tremendamente conservadora como la ha
venido siendo nueva york'
una familia de estas sea la que respalde
al alcalde
pues sí
temas de gente diferente que tienen
puntos en común y que la gente legítima
porque se identifica con los puntos en
común de toda la gente yo recuerdo mucho
esa fecha esta foto la tomé yo porque
esa fue el 11 de noviembre o sea el día
11 del mes 11 del año 2011 hacía un
siglo la misma fecha había pasado un
tema tremendamente importante
y yo elija mi esposa mira yo quiero ser
parte de la historia quería tomarme una
foto porque es nueva york en esa semana
estaba moviéndose algo llama a los
'indignados' de wall street y dije pues
veo y me tomo la foto al lado del torito
y digo y se parte la historia y le
mostramos a los nietos que esa fecha tú
pues como todas las fechas pasa algo
raro y la tenemos no pudimos tomarnos la
foto esta fue la foto que puede tomar
2011 y estoy hablando que el año 2011
esta foto la tomé esta foto la tomé como
una cámara porque los celulares no
tenían las cámaras que hoy tiene no
puede mostrarle una self y porque era
tremendamente complejo nacer con una
cámara
estoy hablando el siglo 21
seguramente allá en los 'indignados' me
crucé con vincular porque él participó
mucho porque actuaba como defensor del
pueblo
hizo campaña por la alcaldía de nueva
york
y su contrincante era ni más ni menos
que un representante clásico de la
institucionalidad
y del poder del mercado ni más ni menos
bloomberg
el presupuesto que tuvo bill de blasio
para sacar adelante su campaña fue de 22
mil dólares y es el alcalde de nueva
york
este personaje que ustedes ven acá
el presidente actual de guatemala
jimmy morales
en guatemala
empieza a pasar lo siguiente hay un
descontento enorme por el exceso de
corrupción que hay y finalmente la gente
logra sacar el presidente y ustedes
saben quién es y morales y morales era
un comediante guardar las proporciones
hagan de cuenta que en colombia el
presidente fuera a su uso
con todo respeto
pero qué pasó el hombre representaba
las cosas de personas diferentes que
tienen puntos en común y que legitiman
una acción
y este señor representaba todo lo que la
mente estaba cansada y obviamente una
sonrisa es mucho más agradable que la
corrupción en colombia si nosotros vemos
la institucionalidad para entender en
esa obra de teatro el rol de la
institucionalidad representada en el
ministerio del medio ambiente daba una
licencia
a una empresa
y ahí aparece el mercado
para que pudiera ser una explotación
minera en cajamarca y la gente sale
y se niega a que eso suceda la
institucionalidad
está
está con la ley
el mercado tiene de por medio una
empresa que quiere invertir e invirtió
así que hacía falta lo podían hacer
pero no el poder está cambiando porque
porque lo común de personas diferentes
legitima una acción y aquí no
legitimaron eso y con todo que cumplían
con la institucionalidad y con el
mercado
les tocó cerrar la mina
eso quiere decir que estamos
recurrentemente en un plebiscito estamos
dando los sistemas de información que
hoy tiene y como vieron en las gráficas
en menos de una década las cosas cambian
muy rápido estamos en un plebiscito
constante al estar en un plebiscito
constante nosotros tenemos que ser
conscientes que tenemos un poder enorme
de legitimar recurrentemente lo que está
sucediendo quiero contarles lo que he
vivido yo
de la transformación del poder ya desde
el mundo empresarial lo que yo viví en
el siglo 20 y en el siglo 21 de esto que
les estoy contando
cuando dirigir la función de bavaria y
zach miller
tuve la fortuna de ser el director de la
función pero la fortuna de tener en mi
oficina este cuadro
este cuadro se llama un hombre fumando
del maestro fernando botero
esta oficina el problema no es que
estudiara mi oficina el problema es que
me gustaba tenerlo allá y obviamente uno
como colombiano y querendón de la
cultura colombiana pues sólo dice
buenísimo vamos a mi oficina y te
muestro mi cuadro de botero además de
que una chica nabai la cosa pero era
era valioso tener un cuadro de botero
allí
por cosas de trabajo tuve que aceptar me
algunos meses y a mi regreso encontré
este titular ustedes lo pueden encontrar
en internet
un electricista se ganó el cuadro y me
sacaron el cuadro de la oficina y lo
peor es que se lo ganó porque lo rifaron
en una tapa de cerveza
eso ese gesto
la nueva empresa dado que se ha
fusionado y que estaba llegando una
cultura nueva lo sencillo como si
hubieran atropellado a mi cultura
yo no valide lo que sucedió allí
y mi actuar frente a la situación fue
uno de los grandes motivos que yo tuve
para renunciar y retirarme de bavaria no
porque me hayan quitado el cuadro sino
que se lo hayan ganado en una etapa de
ser beso
yo no legitime eso y la compañía tuvo
muchos años que explicar y tratar de
volver a ganar terreno para que su
reputación no se verá afectada por la
situación
en juan valdez
cuando estaba trabajando en la primera
línea de juan valdez sale un artículo
the wall street journal que decía la
única marca en el mundo que le puede
eventualmente poner una talanquera hasta
el box se llama juan valdez
feliz porque estaba en balde es vamos a
poner la talanquera empezamos a estudiar
mucho star box y encontramos lo
siguiente que starbucks daba como
promesa de valor a sus clientes y hacia
afuera es que yo vendo café de áfrica
de países pobres y necesitados del
áfrica
es que yo vendo café de centroamérica yo
vendo café de vietnam yo vendo café de
colombia
y es cierto
al ver que sale la promesa de valor de
starbucks nosotros detectamos en juan
valdez
que más que comprarle a los caficultores
del mundo nosotros como juan valdez
teniendo un diferencial del café de
colombia
debíamos hacer dueños de juan valdez a
los mismos caficultores
me monte durante casi cuatro meses todos
los días a todos los pueblos cafeteros
de colombia a todas las fincas cafeteras
de colombia a vender las acciones de
juan valdez salió más caro toda la
logística que la que el capital que se
recogió pero justificó porque porque
ahora ustedes entran a una tienda juan
valdez el primer de primero que ustedes
ven es esta de la tienda de los
caficultores colombianos lo cual hace
más legítimo
esa empresa frente al consumidor y
estamos hablando de legitimidad que es
el actor porque hemos venido hablando
ahora bien
el rumbo
tuve la oportunidad de estar algunos
años liderando esta empresa
el logo de la derecha que el de la
izquierda de ustedes es el logo
tradicional y de alguna manera es el
otro no quiere decir que todo lo que
había hecho yo es ramo pero pero pero se
hicieron algunos cambios pero esta es la
historia de una empresa que recibo una
situación financiera compleja con un
clima laboral complejo y una situación
realmente difícil me voy a referir a un
punto que depende como se mire uno puede
decir que es bueno que es malo y es el
punto de que había cuatro sindicatos
y si nos damos cuenta en el contexto de
la institucionalidad
claramente y obviamente uno tiene que
defender esos derechos
y la compañía la situación que estaba
pues yo tuve que sentarme con todos los
empleados a hablar con todos a generar
una estrategia simplemente de oír sus
demandas y la compañía empieza a
corregir un poco de actividades como
consecuencia de eso la gente decidió por
ella misma porque gente diferente que
tiene puntos en común que se identifican
finalmente tienen un poder gigante hoy
por hoy no hay un no hay un sindicato en
rama y no es que lo hayamos acabado ni
hayamos no simplemente hablamos con la
gente y se legitimó que la compañía
debía salir adelante y al legitimar que
la compañía sale adelante el poder de lo
común
peso sobre la institucionalidad que
siempre ha venido acompañando este tipo
de organizaciones me sorprendió y es un
ejemplo para este tema ahora bien
todo esto quiere decir que en el
escenario de teatro del siglo 21 en el
poder que está cambiando hay un nuevo
actor y ese nuevo actor es la
legitimidad que da lo común y lo común
es eso lo común lo común no es lo que yo
veo de derecha allá que ustedes ven de
izquierda o lo de izquierda que ustedes
ven de derecha ya eso no es lo común
acordémonos que cuando francisco jose
primero no entendió lo que estaba
pasando
se pudo haber prevenido muchas cosas que
pasaron después
en esas épocas
siempre para esa gente vendiendo los
espíritus cuando cuando la ecuación de
poder cambia
aparece gente diciéndole identifícate
conmigo inscríbete acaben para acá y al
final del día terminan en ideas
populistas
ideas populistas que tuvieron al mundo
en el siglo 21 perdón en el siglo 20
bajo dictaduras más duras de derecha
y bajo dictaduras de izquierda
no les parece que justo en este momento
en el que estamos siendo conscientes que
el poder está cambiando está sucediendo
lo mismo
qué está sucediendo en los mismos por lo
tanto no deberíamos endosar con tanta
facilidad nuestra legitimidad legitimar
un amigo puso una foto like
a esta hora 2 y 10 de la mañana 2 y 3 y
4 de la tarde
cuántos likes hemos dado hoy
un montón estamos legitimando algo
entonces por favor intentamos que
estamos en el momento en la obra de
teatro en donde el poder de lo común lo
tenemos la sociedad y el individuo nunca
había sido tan poderosa nunca en la
historia como lo es ahora para que
reconozcamos el poder que nosotros
tenemos conjuntamente y no lo conocemos
tanto y que simplemente seamos
conscientes de que si hay cosas que nos
unen así seamos diferentes nos vayamos
por ese lado sin que no se encuadernan
de ccoo somos de un lado o que somos del
otro o que vamos por el centro no son
las cosas básicas que necesita la
humanidad y hacia allá la invitación de
esta charla muchas gracias
[Aplausos]